all right well let's talk about that's
that guy i need to talk about deep deep
all right so um
you want to talk about something
that's a little uncomfortable for me
right here wildcard admit something okay
this is it all right so do you want me
to open it then
um yeah if you if you want bobby
oh god
this is hard
all right
i just want to announce everybody that
kalila and i are no longer together
um
it's been not over it's not over i mean
the sense that
you know
we
i want to say that kalila is
the love of my life
my best friend
um
if there was a book about my life she
would be
if there was ten chapters she'd be four
of them at least five of them give me
half i'll give you a half of the chapter
um
she changed my life in so many different
ways
she
reinvented who i was
and um
[Music]
yeah
um
and the reason why we're announcing that
is because um there are things that
people
believe online
that aren't true
and i want to address those things
because um
it's causing a lot of pain in our house
um
and i'm gonna start with
my part in it
and my part is this
you know years ago kalila um
had this heart condition
and it started in the
philippines and she we were in the
philippines and i had to carry her into
a taxi and we thought she was going to
die
and um
you know
after that you know at home
we just would have the ambulance at our
house two or three times a week we'd
always constantly go to the hospital at
five in the morning
um
and
at that point in my relationship with
her i changed a bit and it became
um
i was just worried about her keeping her
alive
and i think that it shifted the
relationship you know i mean
um
you know
a lot of the sexual stuff
that i felt before that had diminished
and it became more of a um
caretaker not caretaker this is a
terrible word to use but like i was
extremely worried about her and when
you're in that kind of situation you
know
a lot of that energy and it changes the
relationship at least you know
and then um i began to um
fantasize about
other women i would watch porn every
single night
and you know
and this is over years of this and she
i just distinctly remember there were
moments where we would sit down and she
would be crying going what happened with
us
there's no intimacy um i feel like you
don't know me anymore i want you to get
to know me again
and a lot of times i would do false
promises like trust me i'm just going
through a phase or i'm working on it or
whatever
and i would um
you know
basically
shrug it off
and
tell her that i was we're gonna deal
with it in the future or whatever it
might be but this is
years of this and in fact there were
times where she would
plan vacations so that she could
rekindle
some of the magic that we had lost you
know um
one time we were in
hawaii to do that it was the first time
i went to hawaii
that wasn't a work related thing and um
i think we
we tried you know um
and it it looked optimistic maybe
sometimes but um
i don't know you know i i have to say
that you know a lot of it was my fault
you know um
and you know i was in therapy talking
about it we did couples therapy and
stuff
and um
so eventually got to the point where
obviously people have needs you know
and she had needs and we didn't know
what to do because
of many things number one like i said
you know we
literally are best friends we spend 24
hours
a day together
we created tiger belly together we have
other things that we want to do
we have seven animals we live together
her niece lives with us we're a family
and there's a you know a warmth in the
house and um
it feels
like a family like i said but um but it
got to the point where it's like what
else if i'm not going to change
and i'm not you know and i trust me i
tried um
so it got to the point where i was like
you know we threw out suggestions and
things that um
would you know
i was mindful about how
kalila can
maybe you know um
get her needs fulfilled right and i
threw out suggestions maybe you should
see somebody else you know i mean
and you know i said it a couple of times
um
i also want to address something that
happened with um
my brother
and this is a very sensitive thing for
me um
you know
anyone listening to
tiger belly and are familiar with um our
podcast knows
the things that have been going on you
know i mean it's been a nightmare you
know um
so essentially my brother said some
things to a random person um that we're
not true
um
he has to me personally
apologized i mean for me you know i mean
um
and i think he knows
his mistake but i don't know fully you
know i mean how he feels but um
essentially you know he said things like
you know kalila was a gold digger
um
i have to say that
to people listening um that you know
when i met kalila i had no money
you know i was making
i could tell you what i was making on
the road
i had no other prospects of cash the
only amount of money i was making is
through doing
a b room sometimes
and getting not a door deal but getting
like you know
um
a guarantee you know
so it's not it's not i mean compared to
to all my peers and stuff really and
when i met her
you know she kind of reinvented my thing
i made my money
with her
she has her own money
right
the all the things that i have
in my life right is a direct result of
meeting her and her her and i building
a business together
um
other things have grown out of that like
you know my it rekindled my acting
career
um you know i've done well when it comes
to selling things and whatnot it's been
very good but um
you know without her i don't know where
i'd be you know um
so him saying that she's a gold digger
is not true she's not she's never asked
for anything
um
and she he um said um things like he's
she's keeping
you know i mean
me from other people or right or
something like that or you know
and um
you know during the pandemic
we didn't see anybody you know you know
i'm tired of people thinking that i
don't make my own decisions you know
everything that i do i make my own
decisions i'm bobby lee i
do what i want right and during the
pandemic i was super [ __ ] scared i
didn't know anything about this virus i
didn't leave the house for a year and a
half i didn't even go to the grocery
store for a year and a half right and
and and i didn't see my brother you know
i mean i didn't see my mom right i
didn't see anybody right
um and you know
i think that my brother thought that
that was you know i mean me disappearing
or you mean or you know i mean something
was going on you know i mean that was
like you know um
i don't know i don't know what he was
thinking but um
and um
yeah with all that stuff that he said i
don't i don't know if you guys even if
people even listening knows but
he had texted some random person his
gripes that were absolutely unfounded
and not true
and people have taken that and ran with
it online
and it's really hurtful to kalyal it's
hurtful to me
um
and i just wanted to address it so you
know
just
you know
another thing that i want to add is
you know i
was blatantly
flirting with other people and there was
things that she caught me in that were
like you know i mean kind of um
you know
it took her about i did some lying you
know i mean
and there were things that you know none
of this was like an anomaly or
is that the right word or
you know i mean out of nowhere you know
i mean it's a reaction right to my
behavior
um
i've done a lot of
growth in the last six months and and
changes
um i put some hard boundaries down
and um i don't really give a [ __ ]
to be honest with you
what people think
um
i i don't give a [ __ ]
um and the people that are that are
saying [ __ ] about me and decided [ __ ] go
[ __ ] yourself
i mean because you don't know
my this is my personal life
and this is our life and it's like you
know they're being being very mean
toward
kalila and i've had enough of it you
know
it's unfounded not true
and
she's a good girl
and i love her very much
and
i wish people would stop you know
i really do
um
so that's pretty much everything in a
nutshell for me i um
like
i mean i love kalila i love my brother
as well you know he hurt me
he hurt me
it was painful
that being said
i know through time things will heal
and i
but here's the good news
i i'm we're not stopping tiger belly
we're not um
we're good
we're good
we're not stopping um i'm never going to
see anybody else in my life
i just know i just i have no interest
will be a priest
i have no interest i really have no
interest you know what i mean we just
need time to heal you don't know that
yeah anyway um
that's how i feel you know i'm not
compromising
i mean i'm not gonna watch your movies
yeah
i'm just telling the future if there was
a future i'm not gonna go to your
restaurant i'm gonna eat what i wanna
eat oh yeah i mean i'm not gonna listen
i don't you know i mean i want to play
20 hours of video games if i want to
and whatnot and so that's that but if
you have a real interest i have no
interest in it i have no interest in any
of that no i'm just telling any girls
i'm not listening i will not listen i
will not cuddle
i will not cuddle i will not listen and
i don't give a [ __ ]
all right i'm not doing any of it i it's
it's not who i am
so that's that it's this has nothing to
do with
you know i mean anybody else or my
desires or whatever it has to do with
preserving
tiger belly
kalila and i work work great together we
have great ideas we're producing another
thing together we're going to do a book
yeah i mean and you know um i'm super
excited about the future of my business
here
um we have a great family um
and uh
that's it that's all i wanted to say
it's michael yeah do you have anything
um
yeah i just uh
i'm sad but i love you and
that's it
just give me a second yeah
i just don't want to like say it um
this podcast has like
changed my life i never thought that i
could ever like dabble in anything
creative
like you know that question earlier when
you were like what's one thing your
younger self would like never believe
yeah is that i would even be allowed or
that i would allow myself like a
creative outlet you know
and yeah this podcast has changed my
life and
um
even though difficult
there isn't like a moment of
regret that i spent
10 years of my life with you
you're so much better at talking
i'm just like
i just don't know why i just can't talk
but um
yeah there isn't like um
an even tiny bit of regret that i spent
the last 10 years of my life with you
or that i gave you my firm skin years
i'm a little salty about that
you look great baby
yeah and i'm sorry that um
hit the road yeah
hit the road you look great baby
good luck out there
i i
i have so much
um
i don't know i have
it's kind of like this weird thing that
we we made you know and i just i wanna i
wanna keep going and i want to um
funny enough i think that we've never
been closer
like we've been talking like almost like
every day like since we decided to kind
of like let go of the
the the label
um we've just been
i don't know able to hang out more be
truth more truthful with one another
we're not trying to like mince each
other's words to try to like um protect
each other's feelings we're just being
really like blunt and honest and open
and
it's been so much more
fun being around each other
and
i don't know i just want to
thank you guys for um sticking around
and um i hope that
you know you continue on this journey
with us
oh they will
okay well because um you know i want to
i would i kept telling collateral this
and i want to reassure you both of you
right
of the magic of it it's like that
saturday night when we did the live show
at the ace theater right
there is something there
[Music]
um
that
i kind of got
i mean what why we do it and why we need
to keep doing it